welcome to the next part of our
exploration of the flames in eldon ring
last time i talked about the frenzied
flame and for this video we're going to
explore the flame of ruin
also known as the giant's flame
the very flame that is prophesized to
burn the earth tree
but like before let's start with the
basics and answer the question
what is the flame of ruin
the flame of ruin is anathema to the
earth tree
as such information about the flame is
forbidden by the golden order
due to this it is spoken in hush tones
but prophets who look into the faith of
the order would sometimes glimpse the
flame of ruin
deep within the future of the earth tree
this would lead to an ominous prophecy
regarding the first cardinal sin
however the prophets could not speak of
this forbidden knowledge and should they
speak about it all they would receive is
banishment
but what is it that they glimpse in the
order that would warrant such banishment
what is the first cardinal sin
well they would glimpse of prophecy of
the future
a vision of a maiden ablaze
kindling the forge of the giants which
kept the flame of ruin
and looking above the leaves of the
earth tree would be set ablaze
the flame of ruin may be one or even the
only thing within the lands between
capable of burning the earth tree
fun fact if you start the game as a
prophet catch flame would be one of the
spells you start with and you yourself
may have glimpsed the first cardinal sin
within your prophecies
but who could create such a power that
would defy the earth tree
well who else then another outer god
legend speak of a fel god from whom the
fire giants had borrowed power from
but this power came with a price
a curse to the fire giants
in which they must tend to the flames
for all eternity
it is also said that their hair turned
red due to this curse
and the appearance of this fell god was
a malformed one-eyed deity and is
believed to be evil
but of course this alignment is a
perspective of the golden order as such
it is tainted by bias
it is also said that this god was slain
by queen marika herself
at the end of the war with the giants
long before the shattering before man
turned against man in violence when
godfrey was still elden lord and the
golden order was at its peak
humanity would go to war against the
giants who tended to the flame of ruin
the golden host would be vast and
powerful and would even be joined by the
knights of zamor wielders of frost and
the mortal enemies of the fire giants
despite the power of the flame of ruin
the fire giants would be at a
disadvantage for the champions of the
golden order would cast incantations to
protect against fire
these incantations were created by the
fire monks of the earth tree
the slaughter would be immense
the giants would be struck with this
thorn-like totems which i still have no
idea what they actually are so i asked
the community about them
and majority of the answers were either
that this was a death status effect or
it is a form of briar magic which is a
type of magic used on the guilty
it could even be retribution by the
earth tree itself
but to be honest i still don't know what
it actually is
so i'll leave it as a mystery for now
even the trolls would betray the giants
and move to the side of the golden host
and as mentioned before queen marika
herself would slay the fell god
once their god had been felled the fire
giants would admit defeat which would
also inadvertently free them from their
solitary curse
to serve as fire keepers of the flame of
ruin
however before their defeat the fire
giants had cursed radagon turning his
hair red
a symbol of the flame of ruin and the
fel god a humiliation for one who serves
the golden order
and in retaliation queen marika would
curse the final survivor of the war
she would utter the words
o trifling giant mayest thou tend thy
flame for eternity
a curse given to them once before by the
fell god
one this fire giant thought he would be
free from
instead he would carry this curse until
he is freed from life
soon after the war the fire monks were
tasked to keep guardianship over the
forge
to prevent any from ever igniting the
flame of ruin
contrary to what we see in the game the
fire monks were loyal to the earth tree
long ago
but i believe the fire monks eventually
fell from grace
then came to worship the flame of ruin
before they went down the path of fire
they created spells to protect against
it which were used during the war with
the giants
but when the fire monks were tasked with
guardianship over the flame
they would look into its gaze
its fire would beguile those who would
look within
and they would commit heresy in secret
arghanthy the chief guardian of the
flame would come upon an incantation
that draws directly from the power of
the flame of ruin
a spell that contains fragments of the
fel god still within
he would even come to cast the burn o
flame incantation which directly draws
power from the fire giants then he would
brandish the one-eyed shield which would
depict the malformed one-eyed fell god
of the fire giants
soon their order would devolve into
exiled worshippers and the firemonks
themselves would wear on their chest
armor the grotesque face of the god of
the flame
there would even be tarnished who would
join the fire monks and they would be
known as fling guardians
the taboo of worshiping the flame would
transform into lasting obsessions by
virtue of the fear that they inspire
they would eventually carry sacred seals
that depict the one-eyed god of the fire
giants adorned with braids of red hair
the fireplace who bore the weight of
their duty would eventually carry a
cauldron perched atop their head
furnished with embers
the cauldron would burn and explode
solidifying their faith in the flame
the fire monks would even be on the side
of reichard during the assault on the
volcano manor
eliminating the knights within fourth
lane
and in their home at the top of the
guardian's garrison
you would see their corpses bowing in
reverence to the flame
the fire monks were placed here to be
guardians of the flame prevent the flame
of ruin from ever being used against the
earth tree
and in their duty to guard the flame
they would become lost within
in our quest to become elden lord we
would find ourselves barred from the
earth tree by its thorns and the only
way through would be to burn the thorns
with the flame of ruin but we are not
the first to come to this conclusion
before us there was vike and bernal
both sought the flame in order to burn
the earth tree
though they would approach this sin
differently
vike would seek the frenzied flame
but failed to become lord of chaos and
instead would lose himself to its
madness
bernal would sacrifice his maiden
but she did not envision the flames and
wouldn't be able to kindle the forge
he would end up as a recusant betraying
the golden order
but you tarnished destined to be lord
are assisted by the kindling maiden
herself
she who envisions the flame would
sacrifice herself to the forge
awaken the flame of ruin
and finally fulfill the prophecy and
burn the earth tree
thus allowing you to forge a head
towards your path to elden lord
the ominous prophecy of the golden order
had come to pass
even though the golden host came to the
mountaintop to silence the flames and
yet
america realized that the forge's flame
would never die
so instead of slaying the final fire
giant she cursed it to tend the flames
forever
further ensuring that the flame of ruin
would live on
any prophet who glimpsed the flame of
ruin was banished and they were even
blindfolded so they may not see any
further but perhaps you've heard of the
rumors
the secret
of who the mother of the kindling maiden
may be
you